looking back at the fact that the stream
actually spanned three hours i'm still
very impressed that i managed did not
even build that much in the live stream
that i did for this time lapse so yeah
there isn't too much interesting work
just kind of finishing up the spanish
building over here and seeing whatever i
can even do with the log flume that was
also some there's actually a lot lost
also because of a crush but that's
something to talk about in the future
well actually later on in this video but
i suppose that everybody just has that
sometimes at least I feel like that at
least I'm gonna I'm gonna cry from if
I'm not the only person but sometimes
you just do things in roller coaster can
three and you really don't get as much
done as sometimes at other times and I
feel like this was that sort of episode
then again sometimes you also just need
to take some time to not do the grand
things but just finish up this more but
also important things I suppose that
this is also that sort of an episode so
yeah that's coming your way today and
it's all sponsored by ours is keiko and
I already lost the name of who I even
got the music from but it's some Italian
it composes so I'm her in fitting I
suppose no idea I have to get some new
music though in any case here here that
was actually many problems there was
many problems let me go my way to
butcher English in the moment and there
were many problems who tries to get the
right windows over here or at least I
thought for a second and then somehow
the CTR sind duch colonial said just
came up in my mind and I was literally
the most perfect thing I've ever had so
i just spent a couple minutes they're
just completely just looking at one
window being like manner that sure is a
beautiful window and I really wasn't
expecting to find any really good
windows that would fit the theme so I
was very happy to find out that this one
would actually work and then pop it in
the stream actually taught me to get the
doors from Ralphie's Russian words
because I was also really stressing him
up the doors and I couldn't find any
door that really fits it but for some
reason the Russian doors actually really
good for this sort of thing
so it yeah I did work out a lot better
than expected beforehand a Spanish
building but with Russian doors android
Dutch windows and it even turned out to
be really good so there you go that's
pretty much the restaurant all done I
suppose can also just add at some point
later just add some small planters and
think I'm jigs around it but that's
about it and um I think we I think yeah
that was just right there actually no
it's not just right there all right I'm
checking back in and I think I have some
explaining to do I would like actually
to explain some stuff but I just took a
short polls in my recording it's
actually a fix the video flying because
it was completely broken a lot more
broken than I expected did I have like
three crushes of something something
probably went wrong with the video files
wild crushed but most likely I just done
goofed in certain figures of something
in any case the videos were not in the
right order and there were problems what
you did what good luck let me actually
talk over here what you did you see was
actually real time and was actually the
way the video was supposed to be but
this part over here actually got into
the video twice which was the part after
it just had crushed and but it actually
was kind of funny that after the thing
had crashed i tried to rebuild when i
had before and it didn't really work I
just built some slightly different
things but especially over here with
these buildings it actually did come out
a lot better before the crash I had
these buildings both sticking him out
just as much from the rock so that
wasn't that hard tile difference and
even though it still did look somewhat
all right since the right the left one
was actually also lower than the right
one I think it is actually a lot better
like this and I suppose crashes are
never really that terrible thing as I
often like to create proclaim they are
after I just had a crush I mean
obviously it's really annoying when you
lose your stuff especially if it's a lot
like if it's always of work it's
definitely a big problem but if you just
lose about an hour of work or less it
sometimes can help to even
get you like the same thing done but in
a better way since you can recognize the
mistakes you've made in the past and
kind of do everything all over again and
actually get it done better also usually
if you do have to rebuild things after a
crash you're a lot quicker at it since
you don't really have to experiment with
pieces or figure out what sort of things
you need to do so yeah honestly this did
kind of made me did kind of make me
realize my English is absolutely
terrible today I'm very sorry this did
make me realize that you know pressures
aren't really as bad as they as you know
you sometimes think they are not to
mention that's I was streaming there's
like it but if I was actually live I
would have been slamming my head against
my door at that point but it was live
and it was all nice and we were having a
good time I nobody really cared and it
was all good but I should probably not
talk about that I should probably even
talk a tiny bit about these houses
though I must say there isn't really too
much to these things they aren't really
even they don't really have any sort of
idea to them it's just that I wanted a
tiny bit of buildings on this rock since
I was very much afraid that if I
wouldn't add anything on it it would
just very quickly become a still rock
and you can add as much foliage as you
want a still rock is something that you
want to avoid which is something that
you'll probably see in any theme park if
they do have a fake mountain that
there's most likely something to it like
it's either a volcano which has a core
crater or something or they have some
nice little Alpine houses near the
bottom of the hill or they have a
rollercoaster do all kinds kinds of
crazy stuff on it but I generally tend
to avoid having a completely empty rock
and foliage does not really count as
rock filling since if you filled with
foliage you can fill it with as much
foliage as you like but at some point it
just turns into a big forest and that's
also what you kind of want to avoid plus
it is a bit of a shame if you just like
spent an hour on the rock first and then
completely cover it with foliage I would
kind of recommend against doing that but
the basic idea over here was that I had
a sort of spanish-style theme I've no
idea exactly but I'm sure that somebody
knows about this
like in spain i think you have them too
but awesome turkey there are some
monasteries that i built into the rocks
and they have these galleries of
buildings which you like built into the
cliff faces and i always like seeing
those things so that was in a way the
inspiration for the left buildings over
there though not too much as you can see
they are very incredibly small and then
the building on the right I couldn't
really build it into a cliff face and I
was also afraid that it would turn out
to be a tiny bit too boring if I put
that thing into a cliff face as well so
this is now a little lamb church or
chapel whatever you will and just a tiny
little building just to spruce up the
hill a tiny bit at this point I do feel
like it's safe to just at the foliage
and other things that I really want to
add to it but just having those couple
buildings just spices up the rock a tiny
bit I mean otherwise it really would
have been just a dead Rock and I wanted
to avoid that at all costs and what I
did with this trees I think at the
moment when I was placing those trees
everybody was just like oh my god would
you look at that silver is completely
going nuts he's trying to sink trees
into rocks and it just no but the idea
is usually when you have really high
mountains especially in those like
mountains in Spain you have the small
pine trees on top of them which is not
actually they're not really like pine
trees they're very small pine bushes and
that was the the sort of thing that I
wanted to emulate with the shortleaf
pine that's it from old Spice's trees
and it doesn't do the job perfectly I
mean anybody can recognize these
shortleaf pine from a great distance it
is arguably one of the most overused
trees in walla Costa can three but then
again it seems more fitting than the
smaller pines in all spices points for
example or the lodge from station James
gardening as they look as those look
very northern styled and I really wanted
to get a pine that would also look like
it is a Mediterranean sort of pine which
is also something that many people don't
often realize about Mediterranean
foliage it is not just tsipras it's it's
not just spam the citrus everywhere and
you're good it's more like many pines
there's a lot of different pines in the
military
area and you still have many pine
forests just in a very different way
than you would have in Northern Europe
for example the only problem with it
though I to understand is the fact that
there are barely I don't even think that
I know there are no specific
Mediterranean pine tree custom scenery
sets and that's really one of the
problems especially if you look in Rome
for example they do have that signature
pine which I completely forgot the name
of but yeah just uh that's that's the
sort of thing that I was looking for for
this part of the park so old Spice's
trees pine is just gonna have to do it
at the moment though I was afraid of
over using that thing I honestly can't
spam that thing all over the place how
even at the moments I do think that i
did use it maybe a tiny bit too much but
then again there really was no
alternative that I know of there is of
course the what what is that even called
there is a different pine as a different
pint in and sevens big trees which is a
lot like the shore leaf pine in spices
trees but oh yeah right the lodgepole
pine there we go but that one does look
a lot more northern and just doesn't
have the branches and doesn't just have
that but that look that exact look that
I wanted to have that this pine tree
does sort of have now I did add those
big burgers timbers along the backside
so this is basically just supporting
work at supporting workers boring so I'm
just gonna disregard that for the time
being I did I did want to have that tiny
bit of supporting around the other side
since yeah I was worrying should I or
should I not add some decent scenery on
the back side of the hill and I mean I
shouldn't for a realistic purpose that
it just makes no sense like why would
you even theme that but then on the
other hand I didn't want to leave it
completely untamed I do want to make
this as nice as possible and there's
also the the railway underneath it and
you don't want to see big gray concrete
boxes here on the rig on the railway
that being said by the way it would be
pretty cool to have that train go
through some backstage areas but not
over here this is not a good area to be
backstage so this is sort of I suppose
the middle routes of doing it just have
a simple cliff face on the side of the
railway and just support the log
with big burgers timber above that and I
feel pretty safe about doing nuts that
being said the supports over here which
I'm just working on for the main drop or
something which i'm still not too sure
about since they just i just don't
really feel too realistic then again
when's the last time you really see it
seeing a log flume like this with wooden
supports seriously though when's the lot
the last time you've actually seen a log
flume that looks like this it still
looks like an aqua coaster and that is
definitely a problem that i need to
address I've been thinking of just
getting the I completely lost lost the
name there is also one other water ride
in Europa Park which there is a CT for
in the Europa Park pack of course but I
just completely forgot the name and but
there is that one either what to write
which should have the same curves and
same drops so I should be able to get
that in and just use some track
intersection to add nap to this point
and make the drop look a tiny bit more
log flume ish but if I really want to
get it to work I'm gonna have to
actually head into the because some
scenery I mean the importer into
Sketchup and all that good jazz and
actually make a log flume track for
underneath this which is something that
I'm definitely not looking forward to
and it's something that I'm still
procrastinating to this day and as I am
commentating this I'm already working on
the touch area tiny bit despite the
Spanish I really not being completely
finished but that'll all happen in
episode 93 and so I should talk about
that yeah it's actually maybe in 94 how
am I even at Stu I'm too far ahead I
need to catch up again but um yeah I
figured that the log flume was alright
supported like if I wanted to get the
track done if I wanted to make it look
more like a log flume I could probably
just use the big burgers timber as
supports I figured so this is just a
tiny bit of working on that island this
it's not really important to work on
these areas I kind of just wanted to do
it for myself I don't know if I'm alone
in this but I always just feel like
adding photos to your parks just makes
it look that much more complete and the
more complete that a park looks and I
don't know for some reason it just makes
me it makes it more fun for me to work
on it as well just having this flat ride
for example these little ships over here
but
without any foliage whatsoever is just
really emotion breaking and I just want
to get the foliage in here around this
area just to kind of make the park look
a tiny bit more like it's actually
coming together I suppose the reason for
that is just tiny bit of a motivational
thing for me just knowing that all right
so this episode is going I mean this
part of the park is going to work out
with foliage we're almost there and this
should just fit in the hall of the pike
suppose that sort of the grand idea
behind it though I even I don't really
understand all of my thoughts sometimes
it's not really a problem I don't think
so in any case this was just a tiny bit
like that this is the sort of typical
thing that I think I was really talking
about in the intro just that time
there's the tiny things that nobody
really notices like nobody is going to
notice hmm what a beautiful plants are
right there right next to that flat ride
that's what I really like about this
plug but this is just the small things
that you sometimes just need to get some
tiny bit of time forward to just do in
that peace and quiet and just work on
that nothing spectacular but I always
find it I always find it quite nice to
just be placing flowers this is the sort
of stuff that you don't really need to
think about too much just placing simple
foliage and making simple planters I
mean where you're trying to plan areas
when you're trying to plan buildings
facades or rides on a bigger scale you
really do need to keep thinking about
what you're going to be able to do with
it in the future and have a larger plan
in the back of your head but whenever
you're just miss bamming any sort of
flour into a flower box that sort of
thing just doesn't even happen I don't
know it just kind of like doing the
brainless sort of stuff in roller
coaster can three from time to time
speaking of brainless at this point I
think I decided oh no I didn't even
decide that yes no I didn't I didn't
talk about anything at some point in
time I was going to start working on the
buildings to actually connect the
current Spanish facades with the with
the the main square area which is
something that I still need to do but I
have just not felt inspired for that at
all and I have no idea how I'm even
going to pull that off so every time I
just try that every time I even try
buildings just miserably fills and so
that's something to really worry about
in the future but then again that's
something to worry about in future my
just procrastinated also i figured over
here i could even get the the beach fans
grass in there because i was looking for
a more sort of read looking thing but
that really just doesn't exist there is
of course the read in the harbor sets
but it doesn't really work out as well
if you want to really get more read and
grass near the banks of your rivers so
yeah that's what's that's what to her
[ __ ] fans is actually going getting
spammed for you I've been a complete
know about today but it's time to stream
so uh I'll see you later and thanks for
watching of course as always I'm feeling
like a resource whenever I say that suz
liz is nobody feeling on that and
there's always thanks for watching and
then a little splatter paint on the
screen black is it [ __ ] imbecile